oh god Lucy why so happy new years
everybody and happy 11 million
subscribers who'd have thought I would
have landed on the same day and I'm
oddly enough still sick my voice is
pretty much recovering right now it's
not too terrible cracks everyone to know
what man Wow Lucy you go back Lucy you
Lucy oh gosh Oh Oh God
hi Lucy ha okay all right Lizzie
that's thank you as some of you know
2015 has been a really rough year
there's been a lot of ups and downs to
it some of which you know about some of
which you don't know about and I could
spend a long time talking about and
recapping it and telling you guys about
I'm still sick so excuse me if I call
off I'm gonna try to report stuff later
today but it's only in my voice permits
um but I just wanted to say that you
know at the beginning of this year I
dealt with a breakup that was very very
heavy for me and then I went into the
hospital again because my intestines
almost exploded you know and the various
other stuff happened over the summer and
you know me me and my friends we lost
our friend Daniel and then I had good
Hospital again for my heart thing you
know it has been a very very involved
here and not just for me but for a lot
of the people that I know you know
they've had a lot of things happen to
them in this year both good and bad
that's made 2015 an oddly specific year
to remember it's are an oddly specific
year to remember and I just want to say
thank you for supporting us throughout
this entire year and going into 2016 you
know me and my buddies back in LA where
we're like reinvigorated because you
know throughout all the subscriber
milestones a number of subscribers have
we've been able to get it's it's less
and less about the size of the channel
or the size of the fan base or how how I
compare against other people and more
about just having fun making videos for
the sake of making videos because that's
what has always been about for me and
you know I've had my ups and downs with
that as well but and you know I've lost
that and forgotten it remembered it you
know but down deep down especially
before we all took this vacation we
realized that we are never happier
unless we're just making videos that we
want to make and that's what's really
special about YouTube and that's what's
really special about not turning what we
do into some business where we just
crank out videos on the regular and we
crank out videos which I'm going to be
doing very dedicated on the schedule
that I said I was going to be doing in
2016 I know I keep re promising that I'm
going to do that but this time it really
has gonna be like that I swear 2016 is
going to be such a good year for what we
do in terms of videos and we spending
time with my friends and making more
time
more important things of being able to
give you guys the videos that you want
and giving the videos that you probably
don't want but you watch anyway and go
what the hell are we doing in the first
place and that's sometimes even more
special to what we're doing before so I
just wanted to say thank you guys for
watching and I've been thanking you
straight for almost four years now but
just non-stop endless thank you guys so
much for 11 million subscribers for
helping me get through this year and for
believing me going into the next year
because they're going to be some amazing
things in 2016 some things you can't
even imagine that we have planned
we're gonna follow up on we really
really
thank you guys everybody so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video
buh-bye